y
hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 hace semanas los incendios
forestales avanzan en argentina y en lo
que va del año ya arrasaron con cientos
de miles de hectáreas a lo largo de
distintas provincias del país y para
dialogar sobre esta situación nos
acompaña desde buenos aires argentina
sergio federovisky él es viceministro de
ambiente de la república argentina
también es biólogo y periodista
ambiental sergio federovisky muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24 es
un placer
el contrario muchísimas gracias a
ustedes bueno para comenzar y tomar
dimensión de la problemática que afecta
a argentina cuáles soy la situación en
el país cuántas provincias registrarán
en focos de incendios y en qué estado se
encuentran en un determinado momento
hubo 14 de las 23 provincias argentinas
afectadas verdad
si esas catorce provincias corresponden
al centro y centro el norte de la
argentina que durante el invierno del
hemisferio sur padece normalmente la
temporada seca que en este año se ha
extendido en una sequía prolongada que
ya lleva prácticamente seis meses en
este momento la cantidad de provincias
afectadas es un poco menor pero estamos
muy alertas porque imaginamos que en los
próximos días podría haber gracias a los
aumentos de temperatura y a la
continuidad de la sequía la ausencia de
lluvias probablemente otros casos de
incendios en aquellas provincias en
donde hoy todavía está controlado y lo
que más nos preocupa es mirando hacia el
verano del hemisferio sur la posibilidad
de que esa sequía se traslade a la
patagonia cordillerana donde también
tenemos zonas que habitualmente en el
verano están siendo afectadas por fuegos
y sergio que o quienes están detrás de
estos incendios donde encontramos las
causas
la primera causa es el escenario que
plantea el cambio climático con dos
aspectos relevantes uno es el estrés
hídrico al cual están sometidas la
vegetación incluso la vegetación que
está en pie producto de años y años de
mayores temperaturas promedio el segundo
efecto es el que decíamos reciente el de
la sequía cada vez más extensas como
resultado de la agudización de los
extremos y sobre ese escenario lo que
tenemos es incendios en su inmensa
mayoría intencionales provocados ya sea
por aquellos que por negligencia
desconocimiento malos manejos cosas a lo
largo del tiempo utilizan el fuego como
herramienta sin pensar como herramienta
de manejo de los campos sin pensar en
las consecuencias que se pueden traer y
también tenemos una dosis muy importante
de incendios de liberados aquellos que
encienden fuego para bajarle quizás el
precio a un terreno y después poder
hacer con él alguna actividad lucrativa
o por el contrario utilizar el fuego
como reembolso de la tropa adora
o la motosierra para el avance de la
frontera agropecuaria sergio con
respecto a los incendios en el delta del
río paraná precisamente y en referencia
a lo que decía recién el ministerio de
ambiente y desarrollo sostenible de
argentina los ha denunciado ante la
justicia de hecho el titular de la
cartera al ministro juan cabandié es
querellante no y se está investigando a
empresarios contanos en qué estado se
encuentra la causa le aclaramos a
nuestra audiencia e internacional que
estamos hablando de un territorio de
humedales un hábitat de alta
biodiversidad que es esencial para el
medio ambiente y su conservación verdad
quizás después del del nilo uno de los
deltas más importantes del mundo que va
desde una zona ubicada a más de 400
kilómetros al norte de la ciudad buenos
aires hasta la desembocadura del río de
la plata' y conforman un archipiélago
maravilloso con una biodiversidad única
además de los servicios ambientales que
prestan en esa zona a lo largo de casi
cuatro meses del invierno tuvimos
incendios reiteradas e iu-ca certeza que
tiene el ministerio de ambiente hoy es
que se debían mayoritariamente a un
intento lamentablemente a veces exitoso
de avance sobre el humedal para poder
secarlo aprovechando que es una época en
la cual el nivel del río paraná está muy
bajo hemos comprobado a posteriori que
en esas zonas incendiadas
luego se construyeron terraplenes para
impedir que en el momento en que suba el
nivel del río el agua vuelva a ingresar
y a tomar el lugar que le corresponde en
el humedal por lo tanto lo que hemos
visto es un avance de la frontera
agropecuaria
hemos pedido y así lo ha hecho el
ministro juan cabandié a través de la
denuncia en la cual el ministerio como
tal es querellante ante la justicia
federal de entrerríos que sean
precisamente los jueces quienes
investiguen con todos los dispositivos
tecnológicos a su alcance el origen y la
propiedad de los campos en donde se
iniciaron estos incendios
sergio vamos ahora por un momento a
córdoba la provincia más afectada y
además una provincia muy turística pero
que bueno en este contexto de pandemia
no está recibiendo a viajantes allí hay
13 personas imputadas y 8 detenidas de
que se los acusa en qué situación está
esta causa hablando sobre todo a mayor
le voy a mencionar
si la mayor parte de ellos fueron
identificados en situación de flagrancia
es decir alentando o directamente
encendiendo fuego y algunos son casos de
dueños de campos responsables por malos
manejos realizados con los incendios
precisamente por intentar prender fuego
para limpiar sus territorios o para
manejar de una manera muy poco o nada
recomendable sus campos córdoba tiene la
particularidad a diferencia de lo que
hemos visto en el delta de que allí lo
que más prevalece son los incendios que
llamamos técnicamente de interfaz es
decir que pueden rápidamente alcanzar
poblaciones consolidadas y poner en
riesgo vidas y bienes materiales
justamente buena parte de esos incendios
que se producen en las afueras de
algunas de las ciudades turísticas más
importantes de la provincia de córdoba
como villa carlos paz suelen tener como
propósito ampliar el ejido urbano esto
es quemar zonas aledañas al borde de la
ciudad zonas que no tienen habitualmente
una gran actividad productiva y con el
incendio llevarlas directas
a una incapacidad productiva total para
que el municipio no se vea y se vea
obligado mejor dicho a lotear las a
precio vil
por eso mismo estamos acompañando en
estos días un proyecto de ley más que
trascendente que ha presentado el
diputado máximo kirchner para impedir la
actividad lucrativa y comercial sobre
las tierras que hayan sido incendiadas
durante al menos 60 años o el tiempo que
dure el plan de restauración que evalúe
la autoridad competente en este caso el
ministerio de ambiente de la nación
sergio y ese modelo que buscamos si no
no si contiende ese modo lo que se busca
de ese modo perdón lo que se busca es
desalentar justamente la quema para
urbano inmediato
hablemos surge ahora del agro no porque
en el campo argentino se da una práctica
histórica muy particular que no sé si
será en otros países pero que tiene que
ver con productores agropecuarios que
queman pastizales o desmontan con fuego
en lugar de utilizar topadoras u otras
herramientas en este sentido hace falta
un cambio cultural cree usted
precisamente el presidente alberto
fernández anunció el proyecto de ley de
educación ambiental
hace falta un enorme cambio cultural y
hace falta también un proceso de
concientización dirigida directamente
hacia los productores porque en muchas
zonas del país los productores ya sea
ganaderos zafreros por ejemplo la caña
de azúcar ganado ganaderos ovinos muchos
productores entienden que el manejo de
por ejemplo el rastrojo sobre el campo
el excedente posterior a la zafra en el
caso de la caña de azúcar en los
ingenios se tiene que eliminar a través
del fuego y eso no solamente es una
práctica que no ha demostrado ser eficaz
tampoco es eficaz necesariamente la
quema de pastizales para la búsqueda de
rebrotes en la primavera esas prácticas
digo tienen que ser profundamente
desterradas no sólo porque no son
eficaces sino también y principalmente
porque en tiempos de cambio climático
representan un riesgo enorme altísimo
porque impiden prácticamente la
posibilidad de manejo de ese fuego ya
que rápidamente se propagan también
gracias a la cantidad de combustible que
suele haber sobre el suelo esto es
materia orgánica que ha quedado
probablemente posteriormente a la
cosecha o la utilización de animales
entonces estamos trabajando también para
que la normativa incluya una prohibición
lisa y llana del manejo del fuego con
estas finalidades hablando del cambio
climático muchísimos expertos sostienen
que el modelo económico que sostiene al
mundo es de alguna manera incompatible
no con conservar el medio ambiente y con
la lucha contra el cambio climático
usted coincide con esto es posible un
cambio tan radical
yo no sé si es posible pero en todo caso
si estoy bien convencido de que es
deseable y que es necesario estamos muy
urgencia dos por modificar los
parámetros de producción para que esos
parámetros de producción dejen de ser
sustentables como claramente hoy lo son
el cambio climático es una realidad
contundente y sus efectos ya se están
viendo y la increíble cantidad de
incendios forestales que se están
viviendo y comprobando en prácticamente
todas las partes del mundo al menos en
todas aquellas que ocupan latitudes
similares a la de argentina son una
alerta enorme que tenemos que respetar
no podemos seguir produciendo alimentos
con el grado de insustentabilidad con el
cual se está trabajando o se ha
trabajado hasta el momento la cuestión
ambiental es subversiva ha dicho usted
en alguna oportunidad podría desarrollar
esta idea
bueno la respuesta está en la pregunta
anterior justamente porque lo subversivo
en el sentido de que necesariamente
pensar ambientalmente el planeta desde
otro lugar con otra perspectiva supone
primero cuestionar el modelo vigente y
en segundo lugar y me refiero por
ejemplo lo que dijo el papá en la
encíclica law datos y cuestionar la
definición de progreso hemos llegado
hasta aquí hasta este marasmo enancados
en una definición de progreso que
verdaderamente no ha sido la más feliz
si esto lo ha dicho el papa- por lo
tanto lo que merecemos como sociedad es
una redefinición del progreso un
progreso que ya no se vida en toneladas
de hormigón o en montañas que desaparece
o en fronteras agropecuarias que avancen
o en bosques nativos que se evaporan
necesitamos redefinir el progreso y eso
podrá ser subversivo según mis palabras
lo básicamente lo que s es esperanzador
porque sin cuestionar al modelo vigente
muy difícilmente podamos salir de la
realidad ambiental en la que estamos
sergio nos quedan menos de un minuto
pero no quiero dejar de preguntarle por
otro tema no vinculado a la política
ambiental argentina porque el presidente
alberto fernández presentó una serie de
medidas en este contexto y una tiene que
ver con la erradicación de los basurales
a cielo abierto cuál es la situación
respecto de esta problemática en
argentina
muy sintéticamente la argentina tiene
5000 basurales ha sido abierto que no
son fruto de la clandestinidad sino del
modo en que se trata la basura en la
mayor parte de los municipios de la
argentina tenemos que pasar de un
tratamiento de la basura del siglo 19 al
siglo 21 y ese es un compromiso que el
ministro juan cabandié y quien les habla
y todo el gobierno nacional ha tomado
como propio porque entre otras cosas no
se ha logrado porque el estado nacional
no se ha involucrado en el diseño en el
en la provisión de los recursos y
fundamentalmente en la ejecución de un
programa para el que para mí es el
problema ambiental principal de la
argentina porque no tiene justificativo
económico técnico y ético alguno para
seguir en el tiempo
sergio federovisky viceministro de mente
argentina muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
al contrario muchísimas gracias a
ustedes no por favor a usted ya nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com
[Música]
bien